[Music]
over the past week we played you
recordings of a couple of well-known
figures at cnn chris cuomo who's the 9pm
anchor there
and then jeff zucker who's the president
of the network speaking to their friend
michael cohen in very unguarded ways
if you've heard the tapes you know that
cuomo and zucker are not at all what
they seem to be
in public both of them are sanctimonious
moralizers are given to lectures about
propriety and racism and white privilege
but in private let's just say they are
definitely not that way
zucker and cuomo in other words are
frauds just like the channel they work
for
despite its name cnn is not a cable news
network it is a slickly produced
propaganda loop
every topic cnn covers has been chosen
for its political effect
every word its anchor speak has been
curated to manipulate you
nothing winds up on cnn by accident the
whole thing is a scripted drama
written for the benefit of the
democratic party that's not
overstatement
tonight we have proof this is a
conversation that took place in 2018
between cnn anchor chris cuomo and his
friend the disgraced felon lawyer
michael cohen
the two spoke in person cohen wanted
cuomo to prepare him for an
interview he'd been asked to do on cnn
as michael cohen put it he wanted quote
guidance as a friend more than anything
chris cuomo was happy to oblige
but before we play you the exchange
between the two of them listen first to
how michael cohen describes his
interaction
with another cnn anchor i'm going to ask
you for your advice
on how to handle the interview
that i'm doing first with you erin
burnett wants me to do hers first
says she goes yeah but it's better if i
do it with a woman
as opposed to with you i said i did not
accuse them i said bothering a woman i
said but
chris is a woman so there you have a
news anchor telling a potential guest
that he better talk to her first
because she's a woman at cnn everything
is about identity politics but
regardless of the sex of the anchor
michael cohen was worried about doing
the interview because he knew he'd get
questions about the payments he made to
stormy daniels
he wanted chris cuomo to tell him what
to say
now on tv cuomo might have launched into
a lecture about how it's wrong to send
money to strippers
but in private he skipped that lecture
you will be asked that chris cuomo told
michael cohen
and you can say i did it for him for
donald trump my relationship has always
been for him
i've always said i don't speak for the
campaign i speak for him as his attorney
come on on to elaborate quote and to the
question of motive
he told cohen the response would have to
be you can speculate as to why you think
i did it
all day long but the only answer is my
answer and i just told you why i did it
you don't get to speculate because if
you can't prove that i got paid back by
trump or the campaign
it is slander and defamation for you to
say that i did
now there's no record of whether michael
cohen was taking notes as chris cuomo
was talking he should have been taking
notes because the script that cuomo
provided him is time
tested it's the classic last chance
defense of the obviously guilty
when you don't have a good answer
threaten the person who's asking the
question in this case with a defamation
suit
cuomo seemed certain that would work on
cnn then
he gamed out what would happen next when
cohen
went on his own channel quote i think
the way this conversation goes is almost
exactly the way we're having it right
now
which is where i say this looks shady
and you say it looks shady to you
because you're coming in with a specific
intention
again cuomo advised cohen to attack the
anchor
that's effective but it's not clear that
cohen understood what he was saying
on the tape some of michael cohen's
responses to chris coleman seem
disjointed others sound like he's
grunting
perhaps to make it easier for michael
cohen to follow chris cuomo began acting
out
both sides of the exchange he acted out
the news anchors question
and then he acted out cohen's scripted
response to that question
the conversation devolved into a kind of
one-man play with chris cuomo as the
performer
and michael cohen as the audience here's
one act
and why didn't you just let it all come
out and let the people decide
because it's not a fair process they
wouldn't have had any of the counter
facts and they would have had her
you know if she was somehow convinced to
do it and people decided to believe that
her denials
were somehow less true than her
admissions
um i didn't want to play that game
everything was tilted against mr trump
that's what it is and then either
they'll believe it it'll be like that
there's no way he didn't know
pretty tricky chris cuomo sounds like
he's got some experience making excuses
but the bigger point is this sometimes
when you watch a political show on
television you'll notice the dialogue
seems unnatural
almost like parts of it have been
scripted well at cnn that is
literally what you are seeing scripted
conversation what you just heard there
was the writer's meeting before the show
but chris cuomo was just starting he
then told cohen how to dodge questions
about a shell corporation cohen had used
to make payments to stormy daniels
quote i'm not being shady cuomo
instructed michael cohen to say on
television
i was being legal and i did it my right
way you're wrong about the llc i've used
it for other things i have tons of llc's
i did not format just to do this and
even if i had
my whole point would have been to keep
it quiet but that happens to just
not be true end quote well that's slick
but in case that excuse didn't work
chris cuomo
advised michael cohen once again to
attack the person asking the question
quote unlike the media who is reporting
on this
i don't like to say things just because
they're convenient when they're untrue
again there is no record of how much of
this michael cohen was absorbing or was
capable of absorbing giving his natural
limitations
but chris cuomo kept writing the script
for him anyway
the cnn anchor is going to ask you quote
why didn't you just let it all out and
let the people decide
good question and at this point there's
a long pause in the tape michael cohen
clearly doesn't
have any idea what the answer should be
but chris cuomo knows exactly what to
say
so he jumps back in and takes michael
cohen's part of the colloquy once again
quote because it's not a fair process
chris cuomo barks
they wouldn't have had any of the
counter facts if people had decided to
believe her denials were less true than
her admissions
i didn't want to play that game
everything was tilted against mr trump
said chris cuomo well at this point
michael cohen
starts to get it so chris cuomo decides
to take the training wheels off
and act out the scene together
here it is yes it looks shady yeah we're
gonna find
look you know it's a shady business i
didn't like that politics is a shame
right i didn't like that i had to pay
her to keep her quiet just in case she
decided to
buy again somebody was paying her
it goes on like this and on and on
and on chris cuomo writing the script
for a live interview on his own network
that hasn't yet taken place he gives it
his all
he tries his hardest he plums the depth
of his legal well
but in the end chris cuomo clearly still
senses that his friend michael cohen
could be in serious legal trouble anyway
so he offers to get the big guns
involved
listen how do you get in trouble
you don't get in trouble legally i'll
ask uh
i'm going to make some phone calls on
that and make sure that you can't get
you heard that i'm going to make some
phone calls and make sure you don't get
blank presumably you don't get indicted
chris cuomo
offers that help to michael cohen
unsolicited
and honestly it's a lot more than most
news anchors would do for a guest we can
tell you firsthand
did chris cuomo call his brother the
governor of new york on behalf of
michael cohen we don't know the answer
to that
we do know that whatever chris cuomo did
it didn't work
in the end michael cohen went to prison
anyway but chris cuomo did try
even back then cuomo understood that
michael cohen could be useful
someday and indeed michael cohen
definitely has been useful
tonight two months before the
presidential election michael cohen is
appearing
on cnn in prime time to make the case
against donald trump
in other words in the end it all paid
off